dailyvee what's good headed to Atlanta  the gift goat event Shaquille O'Neal's  in the building I can't wait to see the  film of that because last time Jack  hugged me at the Super Bowl I felt like  accountable aunt that small man's  massive but he's massive in his brain  and his soul so looking forward to that  looking forward to chopping up with a  couple hundred of the gift code holders  looking forward to seeing my man e that  I went to college with 301 the spot you  know a little basketball love a lot of  business q a unveiling gift goat eight  to the crew it's gonna be a nice day and  we're flying in and out so Landon back  here in Newark at past midnight so it's  gonna be a grinder a little throwback to  the way we did it big shout out drock  and uh excited for today